Netflix is filled with unique and
oftentimes overlooked movies looking to
see Jesse Eisenberg as a secret assassin
how about a chilling horror about
African refugees trapped in a haunted
English house here are the underrated
Netflix gems you'll regret not watching
some of the most notable horror movies
ever made find darkness and evil in
everyday places thus exposing the
terrifying possibility that safety and
comfort might be illusory that's the
unsettling premise behind one BR the
2019 feature-length debut from writer
director David marmer finding a nice
apartment in a big city is tough Sarah
who knows this truth well thinks she
gets majorly lucky when she secures the
spot in Los Angeles's homie asilo Del
Mar Apartments but when night falls it
becomes clear she's wandered into a
house of horrors strange noises recur
her cat disappears and everyone starts
acting weirdly the reason Sarah has been
selected by evil nefarious horses to
live in her coveted one-bedroom
residence and she might not get out
alive Becca James of the Chicago Reader
says of the film The Unique timeline
paired with its palpable tension makes
for a memorable addition to the horror
movies about cult's cattle
Jesse Eisenberg almost always plays
nerdy and socially awkward guys however
in American Ultra he gets the chance to
play against type 2 times over as a
laid-back marijuana adult dude and a
killing machine
kind of amazing his character Mike is
quite content with life in his small
Virginia Town the only drama in Mike's
life comes from his panic attacks this
may have something to do with the powers
he displays one night when he lays waste
to a couple of vandals with world-class
Jason Bourne style fighting skills and
suddenly Mike remembers that he's a
brainwashed CIA trained one-man Army and
now the same powers that made him are
trying to take him out Chris McCoy of
the Memphis Flyer writes Stuart and
Eisenberg seem like they're having a
blast and hanging out with them for 90
minutes makes American Ultra a good time
airplanes are an ideal and almost
infinitely reusable setting for horror
movies after all a passenger jet is a
giant metal box hurtling through the sky
at tremendous and dangerous speeds and
disconnected from the regular world if
there are monsters on a plane it's kind
of hard to run away or call up the
authorities and that's where Blood Red
Sky begins at first it seems like a
standard if extremely intense hijacking
drama but these kinds of films always
have an unlikely Hero on board who saves
the day in this case it's Nadia a German
single mother seemingly suffering from
leukemia who boards a long-haul flight
to New York with her young son Elias
when terrorists violently Take Over
Control of the flight it's Nadia who
fights back and it quickly becomes clear
that her illness isn't cancer rather
it's something akin to a progressive and
aggressive form of vampirism the result
is a bloody good time or as Randy Myers
of the San Jose Mercury News put IT
director co-writer Peter thorwarth
splatters the screen with Gore while
tossing in Surprise delirious
preposterousness and even a few touching
moments it's Grand fun in introspective
and action-packed MMA tale both starring
and directed by Halle Berry Bruce is
something special the Oscar winner plays
Jackie pretty bull Justice a once great
brawler who forfeits a fight and retires
a pariah still emotionally smarting from
her ignominious exit years later she
followed is the advice of her boyfriend
slash manager and agrees to participate
in an underground fight ring that could
lead her back to the top all of this
single-minded focus on career and
winning gets complicated however when
her estranged son reappears on her
doorstep Kevin Maher of the times sums
bruised up by saying the film is rescued
at almost every turn by Barry's Fearless
vanity free turn coffee and cream is
about a clashing mismatched pair and the
film itself is a clashing mismatched set
of movie Styles all ramming into each
other the end result is full of action
comedy and even heart Ed Helms of the
office portrays incompetent Detroit
Police Officer James Coffey who begins
dating single mother Vanessa much to the
consternation of her 12 year old son
Kareem to scare off the kind and doting
coffee cream tries to hire a criminal to
intimidate the cop but winds up
embroiling them both in a massive
extremely dangerous conspiracy involving
drug lords and crooked police officers I
know it's hard to believe but most cops
are good people spoken like a true white
man Guillermo del Toro is a masterful
writer and director specializing in
fantasy and horror and where those two
imaginative genres intersect a double
Oscar winner for his work on the shape
of water Del Toro also made emerging
Classics like Pan's Labyrinth and
Hellboy but in 2015 he directed A
lesser-known Fright Fest called Crimson
Peak a Gothic tale that didn't get much
love when it came out even still this
Haunted House story is definitely worth
a watch in 19th century Victorian
England a young American woman named
Edith marries a dashing Sir Thomas sharp
and goes off to live in his sprawling
mansion in the English Countryside but
something doesn't quite feel right about
the home and Sir Thomas's creepy sister
and when Edith's abilities to speak with
and see the dead manifest she learns the
truth behind her spooky visions and the
family into which she probably shouldn't
have just married film writer Richard
Krause called the film quote bloody
terrifying while Trace Thurman of Bloody
Disgusting said you'll be mesmerized by
what what you're seeing on screen
Supernatural Menace is scary but so is
the Dark Side of daily life not to
mention horrific trauma all those
elements converge in his house the 2020
debut feature from writer director Remy
weeks Bull and real Escape wartime South
Sudan and then take a crowded boat with
other refugees making it from France to
England where they're allowed to stay
and given a rotting house to live in
facing openly racist neighbors and
threats of deportation the couple
attempts to embrace their Newfound
britishness and make a go of The New
Normal unfortunately the house is
inhabited by Pure Evil and eventual
witch sends the duo grasping for their
lives and even reality there's a lot
going on in his house and almost all of
it will provoke some kind of emotional
reaction from viewers Tim Gerson of
screen International rights the film has
much to say about grief guilt
assimilation and the ongoing Refugee
crisis and on top of all that it's also
a niche nerve jangler Robert Daniels and
polygon claims the film Breeze a fresh
voice into the haunted house sub-genre
based on the comic book of the same name
by Charles forsman I am not okay with
this is the story of a 17 year old girl
who is trying to deal with high school
the death of her dad and her newly
discovered superpowers Sydney realizes
that when she has an emotional Outburst
as teenagers are prone to do she's able
to move objects in addition to finding
out she's telekinetic she's also trying
to manage the feeling she has for both
of her friends Dina and Stan can you
please stick together
I'd never leave you Sophia lillis is
terrific in her role as Sydney since her
appearance in 2017's it the young
actress has proven herself in projects
like Gretel and tansel and Uncle Frank
and I'm not okay with this is yet
another step in her rise to stardom this
seven episode Netflix original series is
sure to be easily relatable to anyone
who went through an awkward teenage past
it's a wildly different and
unpredictable movie that merges together
movie genres that often rely so heavily
on tropes that they're overly familiar
and predictable in the shadow of the
moon is part sci-fi movie part mystery
and part serial killer story the film
begins in 1988 when Philadelphia police
officer Thomas Lockhart is desperately
trying to find and stop a prolific
murderer whose victims seem to lose all
of their blood at once they find the
suspect Raya but she evades capture by
Falling to her apparent death Flash
Forward nine years later and Raya is
killing again then another nine years
and more murders occur Thomas becomes
the obsessed detective researching the
case for decades as his quest leads him
down the unexpected crime-fighting path
of time travel Chris Wagner of the New
York Times says in the shadow of the
moon is never less than engaging and
it's just about always clever it follows
resembles numerous classic horror movies
in several ways but that may only be a
pretense for writer director David
Robert Mitchell to tear down and subvert
as many tropes as possible knowingly
borrowing a cliche from classic 80s
slasher movies it follows plays with the
puritanical notion of a connection
between sexuality and violence Jay beds
down with her boyfriend Hugh and
contracts a sexually transmitted curse
which will manifest in somewhat
relentlessly following her and trying to
kill her you believe me right
yeah just playing along but unlike those
past horror movies predecessors the evil
and fatal Menace isn't presented with
some mythology backstory or as some
charismatic monster it's just pure
anxiety and Dread rendered violently
real according to lennica Cruz of the
Atlantic it follows represents a
compelling evolution in how Studios and
audiences can and should conceive of its
monsters adherence of the dystopian
sci-fi boom of the 2010s both of the
literary and film version of stuff like
The Maze Runner and The Hunger Games
will find a lot to like in level 16. the
action centers around the students add
an extremely Bleak sedate and colorless
residential girls only boarding school
the enrolled young women are actually
more like prisoners and they've been at
this school since they were infants when
they lived on level zero now as Sophia
and Vivian are 16 years old and live on
level 16. they start to question their
strange lives it's up to Sophia and
Vivian to learn the true nature of their
school and their very existence if they
want to escape film writer Richard
Krause commented on the film saying
mixing elements of social justice horror
and sci-fi level 16 is a genre movie
that delivers both intellectually and
emotionally a little bit of a bullet
riddled crime caper as well as a little
bit of a romantic comedy the Abundant
charm in Mr Right lies in where those
two diametrically opposed film schools
Collide Sam Rockwell plays much in aloof
morally flexible xci agent who spends
his days as a reactive assassin always
working on killing those who've been
hired to kill him but then he meets a
lonely young woman named Martha Sparks
immediately fly and these two fragile
people begin a sweet romance even after
Martha finds out about Munch's violent
world of intrigue she even comes to
enjoy the dangerous excitement a
relationship can offer despite putting
herself In Harm's Way Devin Coggin of
Entertainment Weekly writes the unlikely
Duo of Kendrick and Rockwell make this
candy colored Carnival of blood and
romance hard to resist gosh you're cute
likewise Andy Webster of the New York
Times enjoyed the quote screwball
efferves of Mr Right
a monster calls sounds like the name of
a horror movie but it's actually a
spielberg-esque tale of Boyhood fantasy
director J.A bayona crafts an
allegorical eye-popping film about all
too real and difficult emotions from the
point of view of a child which makes it
all the more heartbreaking yes a monster
calls is about grief but it's also about
a walking talking tree creature with the
voice of Liam Neeson Conor is 13 and his
mother is dying he's just old enough to
know what's going on but young enough to
have no idea how to cope he can't turn
to his Stern grandmother and his father
took off long ago an unlikely and
impossible Ally arrives just when Connor
needs him he is the monster a massive
sentient yew tree who offers to tell
Connor three grand Tales after that
Connor must share one of his own it's
all a little frightening and also
wonderful and the revelation of where
the tree learned his stories will
definitely leave the viewer moved and
misty-eyed Sarah Ward of concrete
playground rights of the film as a
literal visual illustration of the power
of creativity to help process life's
woes a monster calls excels
be careful what you wish for Knight
books subtly suggests because wishes
just might be real or at least magic is
and it's a powerful and oppressive
Source if placed in the wrong hands Alex
is a little kid who loves to write scary
stories until other kids call him weird
for it and he Endeavors to never write
again not long after a happily Wicked
and very stylish witch traps him in her
magical traveling all-consuming
townhouse and orders him to write her a
scary story each night or she'll kill
him Alex teams up with another of the
witch's young captives Yasmin to survive
and finds a way out of the villain's
clutches by defeating the powerful magic
that's all around them looper's own
Matthew Jackson shared his thoughts on
the film sharing it's not just an
effective little family horror Adventure
but an Ode to weird kids everywhere
that's good
really good thanks
horror movies are most effective in
delivering truly visceral and bewildered
responses from audiences when they speak
to deep-seated widespread fears they
become relatable on a deep even
subliminal level and great horror
filmmakers use tropes like ghosts
monsters and other supernatural
phenomena as allegories for what truly
can eat Us Alive that's what's going on
in no one gets out alive a Netflix
original from visual effects Creator
turned first time feature director
Santiago mengini ambar is an
undocumented immigrant living in a
rundown women-only boarding house in
Cleveland beyond the physical disrepair
there's a bigger creepiness to the place
which becomes clear when the ghosts of
previous borders start to frighten anbar
but since she's living in the U.S
illegally she can't seek out the help of
authorities or find Refuge elsewhere
because she fears deportation no one
gets out alive is A Haunted House story
but it's really about the plight of
recent immigrants trying to survive in a
new new country the old ways is a
haunting Thriller about haunting things
partially in English and partially in
Spanish it's a horror movie that blends
traditional and familiar elements of
classic horror movies with Mexican
folklore and tales of Witchcraft Bridget
Callie Canales portrays Christina Lopez
a Mexican-American reporter who heads
back to her hometown near Veracruz on
the Gulf of Mexico to research a story
about the area's many witchy Legends her
information gathering quickly turns from
academic into something much darker and
Hands-On when a collection of local
residents kidnap and hold her against
her will the bruja means to use her
powers to rid Christina of the demon the
group believes possesses her Michael
Talbot Haynes of film threat praised the
old ways as the best exorcism movie
since the Exorcist while Deirdre crimens
of rumorg magazine found it to be an
all-around good and scary movie Red Dot
is an action movie broken down into its
most basic elements it's about two
people in an unfamiliar environment
being chased by an unknown party trying
to kill them for unknown reasons the
film starts out with Nadja and David a
couple expecting a baby but otherwise
disconnected who embark on a hiking
getaway in snowy Northern Sweden after
some awkward and unsettling encounters
with locals Naja and David soon find
themselves desperately trying to survive
brutally violent and surreptitious
attackers eventually the deadly game of
human hunting all makes sense but
viewers will enjoy putting together the
tragic pieces Jade badowski of decider
says Red Dot is quote tense disturbing
and well made Dave Franco is primarily
known as an actor in comedic films like
The Disaster Artist and 21 Jump Street
but as a screenwriter and first time
director with the rental he shows his
filmmaking Ambitions can Veer to the
Sinister And the tried and true to
Hallmarks of Horror
foreign
the rental explores the slight
creepiness that can come with
temporarily living in the home of
someone else it also takes the idea to
its darkest depths exploiting the
unsettling feelings of isolation that
can accompany a weekend getaway married
couple Charlie and Michelle along with
dating pair Josh and Mina rent a remote
beach house for a few days but when they
arrive things feel a little off
particularly because someone is spying
on the foursome and slowly carefully
hunting them down and it might not even
be the rude racist property owner when
Lima of australiasnews.com says
delivering solid Thrills and an ugly
portrait of disintegrating relationships
the rental is a clever meld of drama and
horror likewise Susan kamyab of this
chick's flicks called the film a solid
Thriller that subtly goes from
nerve-wracking drama to shocking Slasher
the ritual plays off the Lost in the
wood scenario while introducing new and
Innovative elements to the
well-established sub-genre of scary
Forest flicks four old college buddies
seek comfort and connection after the
Unexpected death of a fifth friend they
go hiking in a rural area in Scandinavia
and encounter ancient poorly understood
and deeply evil forces that wish them
harm the ritual according to Alan
scherzel of the Village Voice achieves a
tense and devilish power leaving you in
the dark with these guys Katie Walsh of
the Los Angeles time set of the film
it's efficient and highly effective in
its style relying on sound creepy
production design and the men's own fear
and misjudgment to create the sense of
pervasive Doom not much sleep happens in
the sleepover it's a heist movie and a
kidnapping paper with a Switcheroo in
that it's the kids who need to save the
grown-ups it's one of those movies where
tweens get to stay up all night and go
on a Grand Adventure goofy mother Margot
was once an international Master Thief
who quit that life entered witness
protection and married her dweebie
husband Ron the past comes back to haunt
her when her old team recruits her by
way of kidnapping her and Ron and forces
her to help them steal a precious Crown
from a dignitary your mom is getting
cooler by like the second when Margot
and Ron's kids come home to an empty
house they figure out their mother's
secret life and potential whereabouts
and set out to rescue her with the aid
of criminal and spy gadgetry she left
behind small crimes is a small crime
movie about people on the fringes of
society who have seemingly resigned
themselves to life on the edge it's an
it's an addling take on the crime drama
genre Nikolai Koster wildau plays a
fallen from Grace police officer just
emerging from prison after serving six
years for attempted murder he wants to
get his life on track and redeem himself
with his family but they don't want much
to do with him this helps to send him
headlong back into a world of corruption
organized crime casual violence and
other CD elements Mike D'Angelo of the
AV club said if the film came across as
jaded and cynical it might well be hard
to take instead it seems weary and
defeated as if some people are simply
born to fail with the Waterman David
oyalo both takes a supporting role as a
put upon father and directs this
dazzling family-friendly fantasy drama
about the power of a child's imagination
it's an Escapist movie about the
pleasures and necessities of escapism
the Boone family has just moved to a
Tiny Town in Rural Oregon where
eleven-year-old Gunner finds Alice in
the local bookstore and it's here that
he researches detective stories and
cancer because his mother is coping with
leukemia Gunner needs breaks from
reality and he finds one when he hears
about the watermen a mythical figure who
factors large in local Legend So Gunner
pays a local nerdu well to take him deep
into the woods to see if they can find
this ghostly individual who may possibly
be real and who may possibly be immortal
their Quest winds up equal parts surreal
magical and mysterious Adam Graham of
the Detroit News commands oyelowo for
his storytelling and big imagination and
describes the film saying it's a
sensitive coming-of-age story about loss
friendship and the need to believe in
magic
with his headlining role in the twisty
harrowing 2018 action thriller the
wedding guest Dev Patel proves he's one
of the most versatile and captivating
actors working in movies right now Patel
plays Jay a British man with criminal
ties hired to travel to Pakistan and
violently kidnap a woman named Samira
from her own wedding he's methodical
careful and cold-blooded and yet what's
supposed to be a simple and horrific
task completely falls apart innocent
bystanders get victimized Ransom
payments go awry and both the failed
kidnapper and the ill-fated bride to be
are harboring some pretty major Secrets
simran Hans of The Observer said that
the film pays homage to the quote Neo
Noir genre while MV Moorhead of Phoenix
magazine said the story feels realistic
in a way that this sort of Noir material
doesn't always what lies below begins
innocently enough Liberty Wells is a
quiet slightly awkward teen who's just
finishing up a spell at summer camp when
she heads back to meet her mother at an
idyllic Lake house but Mom Michelle has
some news she's got a new boyfriend and
he's at the lake house too at first the
only thing that seems truly off about
the hunky John Smith is his mysteriously
generic name but as Liberty gets to know
him he emerges as a truly and alarmingly
weird guy he hangs out at the lake all
year engaging in some kind of
cryptically explained research about
various species he can also Sleepwalk
into a lake into a glowing light under
the water and come out totally dry his
oddness grows ever the more Sinister and
life-threatening her mother can't see
that John Smith is dangerous and it's up
to the teenager to unravel and expose
what's really going on before someone
ends up dead Drew tinnin of dread
Central says the film really works as a
sexy sci-fi thriller that definitely has
a will to be weird so if you're in the
mood for some creepy science fiction
head over to Netflix to find out what
truly does lie below very awesome thanks
generally speaking westerns are often
filled with stock characters Cowboys and
can-do settlers who meet every challenge
with style but the reality of life in
the old west must have been objectively
terrifying at times and this is the
theme explored by director Emma Tami in
the 2018 Western psychological horror
movie The Wind in the 1800s Lizzie
Macklin settles on a lonely patch of
land out on the frontier where she's cut
off from civilization and most of
humanity for long periods of time she
faces Relentless challenges particularly
the endlessly howling wind that starts
to play tricks on her mind in fact she's
starting to believe that there's
something evil and Sinister afoot
forcing her to resort to Desperate
Measures Audrey Fox of crooked Marquis
said the wind is a piece of surprisingly
intimate female-oriented historical
horror there are no jump scares it opts
instead for a tense pervasive sense of
dread that permeates the entire film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]